Napoleon Dynamite is the kind of movie that
rewards repeat viewings, thanks to some very
subtle jokes and hints.
There are plenty of odd details you just can't
catch the first time around because you're
too distracted by all of the other odd details.
Here are a few.
When we first meet Kip, it doesn't seem like
he's particularly honest about how he spends
his time:
"Napoleon, don't be jealous that I've been
chatting online with babes all day."
In fact, Kip notes that it's one babe in particular
who he spends hours talking to.
Late in the film, we finally meet Kip's lady
love, LaFawnduh, who arrives on a bus and
quickly becomes an inseparable part of Kip's
life.
Kip and LaFawnduh are clearly different in
just about every way, but they're able to
start a relationship surprisingly well.
It's actually quite touching on some level,
but since Kip was also bragging to Napoleon
about another lie:
"Besides, we both know that I'm training to
become a cage fighter."
"Since when, Kip?
You have the worst reflexes of all time."
"Try and hit me Napoleon."
We're left to wonder: what exactly did Kip
tell LaFawnduh about himself to get her interested
in the first place?
From the moment we first see Uncle Rico, it
becomes clear that he's an unusual man.
He spends a lot of his downtime throwing footballs
and recording himself doing quarterback moves
on his camcorder.
Rico is a man pining for the glory days when
he was a high school star with prospects,
but it turns out his particular delusions
of grandeur sometimes reach dangerous heights.
"How much you wanna make a bet I can throw
a football over them mountains?
Yeah."
Uncle Rico is desperate enough to believe
that he can purchase a device that will allow
him to travel through time.
It's alarming that this delusional man has
been placed in charge of two young relatives,
one of whom is still in high school.
He might have the best intentions, and he
might have some profound sadness in his life,
but Uncle Rico is frighteningly out of touch
with reality.
Speaking of that time machine, we get to see
it in action when Napoleon discovers it laying
out on the dining room table and opts to give
it a try.
After reading the instructions, Napoleon has
Kip plug the device in.
He's immediately and violently electrocuted
until his brother pulls the plug.
What makes the scene a little disturbing actually
comes at the moment when Kip lets a smile
cross his face as Napoleon writhes in pain.
Siblings will fight, and we've all been guilty
of laughing just a little too much when a
friend or relative was injured in some minor
way, but Kip's smile here feels slightly creepy.
Did he know the time machine wouldn't really
hurt Napoleon that much?
Did he just not care?
Is he slightly sociopathic?
We'll never know.
Pedro is a character who stands out in the
landscape of Napoleon's high school.
This is part of what draws Napoleon to him,
but it also creates a strange relationship
between Pedro and other adults and students
at the school.
It reaches its apex late in the film, when
Summer is giving her student body president
speech:
"Who wants to eat chiminy-changas next year?
Not me.
See, with me, it'll be summer all year long."
It's an obvious reference to Pedro's Mexican
heritage, and it's part of a pattern of casual
racism that lingers at various points in the
film.
Be nicer to Pedro, people!
The film's most famous scene occurs during
the student body president assembly.
Pedro, in need of a skit to support his candidacy,
is ready to give up, but then Napoleon shows
off his sweet dance moves to the tune of Jamiroquai's
"Canned Heat."
It's a classic moment of 2000s cinema, and
it's largely thanks to LaFawnduh, who, upon
learning Napoleon is interested in dance,
tosses him an unmarked cassette and tells
him that her cousin made it.
Now, that could just be a mix tape that her
cousin made, but we're given no label to tell
us that.
So, keeping in mind that this is a stretch…
is LaFawnduh's cousin Jamiroquai?
Uncle Rico is a man with a many flaws.
He's constantly looking to the past, he's
a bully to Napoleon, he enlists Kip as a pawn
in his schemes, and he also happens to be
a bit of an egotistical liar.
As the film goes on, though, his sleazier
side sometimes takes a turn toward the full-blown
creepy.
Yes, his delusions often make him into a buffoon,
but consider various incidents in the film
that escalate nearer to the end.
He tries to get Trisha and Summer to try his
breast enhancement scheme, then corners Deb
at her photo studio, tells her to call him
"Uncle Rico," and passes her a brochure while
lying that it was Napoleon's idea.
Then, of course, there's the moment with Rex's
wife Starla.
"I don't feel comfortable reading this."
"Oh, that's fine, that's fine.
But do you feel comfortable with me?"
Finally, the post-credits scene puts the icing
on the creepy cake when he sniffs LaFawnduh's
garter after catching it at the wedding.
It's played for laughs, but it's also pretty
unnerving.
Early in the film, Napoleon helps to establish
his particular brand of awkwardness by telling
Pedro that he doesn't have "any skills," lamenting
that he's not a martial arts master or computer
hacker, though he is able to draw a little.
But as the story unfolds, Napoleon just keeps
proving himself wrong.
At the FFA competition, he's able analyze
milk correctly with almost no hesitation.
He's able to learn the dance that wins the
election for Pedro in a matter of days simply
by practicing diligently.
Then, he reveals his fishing skills.
"I caught you a delicious bass."
And in the post-credits scene, he's tamed
the horse Kip and LaFawnduh are supposed to
ride away on.
It's a heartwarming ending; the film proves
that Napoleon does indeed have skills.
He just has to go on a journey to realize
what they are.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel, and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.